let's just for the sake of of our
imaginations assume that I am the local
loan shark and you need a dollar for
whatever purpose is to to feed your
children or start a business or or buy a
new suit whatever it may be and you come
to me and you say Sal I need a dollar I
need to borrow it for roughly a year and
I'm going to get a great job where my
children will get a great job and I'll
pay you back in a year and I say oh that
sounds very good and and I will lend you
a dollar for the low price or the low
interest rate of one hundred percent
annual interest so if you borrow one
dollar if you've had 100 percent
interest if you borrow a dollar in a
year from now I want that dollar back
and I also want a hundred percent of
that that's the interest rate the
interest rate is essentially what
percentage of the original amount you
borrow that's called the principal and
in finance terms that's how much I'm
essentially charging you to borrow the
money so it'll be one dollar principal
principal that's what you're borrowing
and of course you have to pay that back
plus 100 percent Interest one dollar
that's 100% right 100% interest and a
year from now you are going to pay me
the principal plus the interest so you
were going to pay me two dollars
well you're a fairly desperate so so you
say okay Sal that's okay but seeing that
this isn't the lowest interest rate that
you've ever seen
I think the federal funds rate is at
something like two and a half or three
percent so clearly my my hundred percent
is is what would make any loan shark
proud you figure well I want to pay this
thing off as soon as possible so you say
Sal what what happens if I can if I have
the money in in six months well say okay
that that's reasonable for six months
since you're only borrowing it for half
as long I tell you what I will lend you
you just have to pay me fifty percent
after six months so this is after one
year one year after six months I want
you to pay one dollar of principle
plus fifty percent interest plus fifty
cents
alright that's fifty percent and the
logic being that you know if I'm
charging you 100 percent I'm charging $1
for you to keep the money for the whole
year I'm only going to charge you half
as much to keep the money half the year
and so after six months I would expect
you to pay me $1 fifty one dollar fifty
and this is after six months and then
you say okay salad that that sounds that
makes sense so far but let's just say
that I want to I intend to pay back in
six months but just in case I don't have
the money in six months
well I still just owe you two dollars in
a year and I say no no that that that I
can't deal with because now I'm I'm
giving you the possibility of paying off
earlier and if you pay this money
earlier then I have to figure out where
I'm going to essentially who I'm going
to take advantage of next while if I
just lock in my money with you I can
take advantage of you for for an entire
year so what I say is if you want to if
you want to what you're going to have to
do is essentially rebar owe the money
after six months for another six months
so instead of me paying you instead of
me charging you fifty cents for the next
six months I'm going to charge you fifty
percent for the next six months so this
is how you can view it you and day one
you borrow a dollar from me in six
months you pay a dollar fifty right and
we decided that 50 percent was a fair
interest rate for six months right so
let's say that you really do need the
money for a year so we will just charge
you another 50 percent for that next six
months now that other 50 percent it's
not going to be on your initial
principle now after six months you owe
me a dollar fifty so I'm going to charge
you I'm going to charge you so now so
this is starting on the next period you
do me a dollar fifty and now I'm going
to charge you fifty percent of that so
that's seventy five cents so still a 50
percent interest rate for the six months
but your principle is increased right
because it was the old principle plus
the old interest and that's how much you
owe me now and I'm going to charge the
interest rate on that
and so now that equals $2.25 over a year
so you look at that and you're like wow
you know justjust to be able to
essentially have this option to pay
earlier I'm I'm essentially on an annual
rate my annual rate looks a lot more
like one hundred twenty five percent
Interest right because my original
principal your your original principal
was a dollar and now you're paying a
dollar twenty five in interest so you're
paying one hundred twenty five percent
annual rate so that that looks pretty
bad to you but but you are I guess in a
tough bind so you agree to it and and
and I explained to you that this is
actually just a very common thing even
though it looks suspicious you it's
called compounding interest it means
that after every period if we say
something compounds twice a year after
every six months we take the interest
off of the new amount that you owe me
you could pay me back what you owe me at
that point or you could essentially
rebar owe it at the same rate for
another six months
so you say okay Sal you're overwhelming
me a little bit but I need the money so
I'll do it but once again you know on an
annual basis hundred twenty five percent
looks even worse you know fifty percent
over six months still isn't cheap what
if I have the money in a month what if I
have the money in a month where I say
okay here is the deal same notion
instead of charging you 100 percent
instead of charging you 100 percent per
year I'm going to charge you so this is
that's this is scenario one this is
scenario two I'm going to charge you
1/12 of that I'm gonna charge you 100
percent divided by 12 and what is that
it's it's 12 goes into 108 eight and a
half percent eight eight and a half
times right yeah eight times 12 is 96 so
then you get another half in there right
so now I'll say well if you want to pay
me on any given month I'll just charge
you 8.5% per month and once again though
it's going to compound so let's say you
start with one dollar after one month
you're going to owe me that one dollar
plus eight point five percent so after
one month you're going to owe me one
plus eight point five percent of one so
Plus Oh 8 5 which equals 1.08 5 and then
after a month you're going to owe me
this plus 8.5% of this so it would be it
would be essentially 1 0.085 squared and
you can you can do the math to figure
that out
and then after three months you'll owe
me one point oh eight five to the third
and after a full year you'll actually
owe me one point oh eight five to the
12th power and let's see what that is
I'm gonna use my little excel here let's
see if I have plus 1.08 5 to the 12th
you'll owe me two dollars and sixty-six
that equals two dollars and sixty-six
and you say okay that's acceptable
reluctantly because this is now what 166
percent effective interest rate and and
just to keep in mind all I'm doing is
I'm compounding the interest right this
was a dollar a dollar eight and a half
cents and I think that makes sense to
you and the reason why this is squared
is because this is going to this is just
this principal times one point oh eight
five another way to view it is this is
the same thing as let me do it in a
different color as its equivalent to
this plus 0.08 five times one point oh
eight five right so it's one point oh
eight five plus 0.08 five times one
point oh eight five so if you think of
if you think of this as one times one
point oh eight five and this is point oh
eight five times one point oh eight five
then you can distribute you can take out
the one point oh eight five and you
would essentially get one point oh eight
five times one point oh eight five and
it keeps going and so this is so now in
this situation we are compounding the
interest it was we said it's essentially
a hundred percent interest but we're
dividing it by twelve per month but
we're compounding it twelve times
so in general what's the formula if I
want to compound it n times so how much
you're going to have to pay me at the
end of a year well let's say you want to
compound let's say you want to pay every
day if you want you want the ability to
pay every day and I say that's ok so
each day per day I'll charge you 100
percent which was my original annual
rate divided by say 365 days in a year
but I'm going to compound it every day
so after every day you're going to owe
one point what is this number
let's see that number is 100 divided by
365 whoops plus 100 all right 365 so
it's 2 that's point point two seven
percent Oh two seven percent after every
day you're going to owe me this much
times the previous day so after 365 days
you're going to owe me this to the 360
fifth power
so in general oh I just realized the
amount of time so I will continue this
in the next video see you soon